one of the most infamous men in the
world Andrew Tate's misogynistic tirade
have been viewed billions of Times
online he's now been effectively banned
though from the internet he doesn't
think that's fair tonight I'm going to
try and work out if it is
[Music]
from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored
well good evening from London and
welcome to special edition of Piers
Morgan uncensored Andrew Tate one on one
he's the most famous man you probably
never heard of with billions of views
online at one point this year more
people were searching Google for Andrew
Tate and Donald Trump or Kim Kardashian
former professional kickboxer he was
kicked off big brother in 2016 after a
video emerged of him striking a woman
and what they now both claim was the
consensual sex game he since made
Millions as a pornographer and casino
owner in Romania but it's his online
videos that have made him notorious
across the world posing as a Playboy
with fast cars cigars weapons and cash
he rant about his often scandalous views
on women or instruct a female to provide
sustenance
cool so I think my sister is my her
husband's property yes tell young men
they can get as rich as him by paying
for his digital life lessons
I have a hundred
I'm gonna teach you to allow you
to use money in
Clash the net has clothes on Andrew Tate
while Millions still share his videos
it's effectively banned from the web
booted off Facebook YouTube Instagram
Twitter and Tick Tock to his fans is a
misunderstood satirist and the victim of
big Tech censorship to many others he's
a malicious misogynist tonight I'll try
and get some of the truth
well some of the opinions Andrew Tate
shares in his videos are undeniably
deeply offensive we're going to show you
some of them on this show I think you
should see them yourself not simply hear
what he says about them or what other
people say about them tens of millions
of people across the world follow Andrew
Tate and when the big Following comes a
big responsibility as well as a public
interest in holding his views to account
if outrageous opinions are read aloud
they can be challenged and exposed for
what they are they're silenced the
person holding these views can become a
martyr so that's why I invited Andrew
Tate to come here tonight and he joins
me now live so Andrew well welcome first
of all
um you come all the way from Romania to
do this interview correct what do you
hope to achieve from this interview why
are you here it'd be interesting to have
a conversation with you you've certainly
been uh the subject of your own divided
opinions in the world there's a lot of
people who would say some of the things
you say are perhaps dangerous or toxic
so I thought you'd be a good person to
speak to about this subject I didn't
know much about you before this year and
then I suddenly became very aware of you
as the world did because was as I said
earlier you you were the number one
subject searched on Google ahead of
Donald Trump I don't think it was even
possible why did you get suddenly so
popular stroke Infamous do you think I
exploded uh I certainly didn't do that
with magic I've been on the internet for
a very long time I think in the world we
live in now as the other side the other
side the people who disagree with me as
they get more and more tyrannical in
their censorships and their hate mobs
Etc as standard masculine practices are
deemed toxic I didn't put a magic spell
on everybody I managed to accumulate a
large amount of affinity with the male
populace Across the Western world
because I'm simply saying things that
many men believe think and feel the
problem I would say is I want to play
you just a clip off the top this is from
Joe Rogan he's somebody I absolutely
love sure and I think it explains to me
what my what I presume my issue with you
is going to be right correct and you you
have absolutely got the right to try and
persuade me otherwise sure but Joe Rogan
said this about you
my 12 year old and my 14 year old asked
me about Andrew Tate
I said he's a legit world champion
kickboxer I like him a lot why do you
like him and I was asking him they said
he says a lot of funny stuff on on
Twitter and Tick Tock he [ __ ] up with
the misogynist yes because if he didn't
do that if he just said the pro mail
stuff
so I thought that was interesting
because when I've gone over everything
that's been at the center of the debate
about Andrew Tate I come down with Joe
Rogan in the sense that there's a lot of
stuff you say I agree with you know I've
got three sons in my 20s it's not easy
actually being a young male in the
modern world
um and I think a lot of the things that
you say about that uh can resonate with
them the problem comes with the I don't
know 10 20 or whatever of your output
which on the face of it appears to be
blatant misogyny and when you couple
that with your massive influence and
huge reach that is why the social media
companies have decided to effectively
cancel you I don't believe in
cancellation I don't believe in
censorship particularly that's why I've
invited you to come on the show
um but I do think a lot of the things
you've said are blatant misogyny do you
accept that so you made a very
interesting point there you just said on
the face of it appear to be blatantly
misogynistic I understand that on the
face of some of the long format content
I've made 8 if you're going to take a
few seconds of hours chop it up put it
all over social media accompany with my
massive Fame then things can absolutely
not really be taken out of context I do
not hate women in any regard I have no
negative relationship with women no
women have come forward saying I've hurt
them I've no criminal record for hurting
women there's no way I can be seen as
the face or the devil in regards to how
men treat women on on the planet I'm
absolutely not really the opposite I
believe in protecting and providing I've
been misunderstood there's been large
contingents of people who have tried
very hard to purport lies about me and
and the the truth of the matter is I've
been producing content for a very long
time hours and hours of videos been cut
down to two or three seconds of clip
those clips have gone viral and people
misunderstand me I think you use this
phrase and be taken out of context and
I'm not I'm not sure that is correct in
the sense that it still comes out of
your mouth it's some of the things
completely some of the things you've
said I just think are blatantly well
let's do let's do them well let's hear
them let's go through some sure right so
you said this about me too stroke rate
this is probably 40 of the reason I
moved to Romania in Eastern Europe none
of this garbage flies you go to the
police and say he raped me back in 1988
they'll say well you should have done
something about it back then yeah so the
point I was making was obviously at the
height of the metoo Scandal and also if
we look at Amber Heard and Johnny Depp
there's been a lot of high profile cases
where men have been accused of things
they did not do without evidence their
lives have been completely and utterly
destroyed when I say these things people
sit and say that oh he hates women I
don't hate women I think rape is
disgusting I would take a stronger
stance on rape than the British
government I think these people should
face the death penalty but to sit and
say that women without evidence can go
forward and just make up accusations
against men even though they've been
repeatedly proven to destroy men's lives
at will is absolutely what about a woman
who was raped back in 1988 and then the
man should face absolutely complete
Justice
would you understand that when that clip
appears on tick tock as a clip and all
right that's a clip completely okay but
it's still something came out of your
mouth do you accept that when that
appears on Tick Tock a lot of young
maybe not as smart as you young men
right impressionable teenagers we'll
read that and go what's he saying is he
saying that rape doesn't exist no I
completely I'm not going to sit here as
a professional and say that I can't be
taken out of context what I will say is
that one small sentence you've taken was
from a one hour video where I explained
that of course rape is disgusting of
course everybody should be punished for
their crimes regardless of when they
happen but people are not perfect male
and female and if you give women the
opportunity to destroy men's lives
without evidence there's going to be a
contingent of women who will do that I'm
trying to make a balanced and nuanced
argument in a world where people have no
intentions fan they're going to take a
few seconds put it online decide
someone's good or bad not be interested
in the longer format video and here I am
no I'm certainly a person who takes
personal responsibility that's who I am
as a person but we live in a world now
with Tick Tock videos five or six
seconds long there's no content do you
think do you think women are the
property of men no the point I was like
why have you said they are I made a
religious point I said that when a man
marries a woman the woman's father walks
him down the aisle walks her down the
aisle and hands her way to the man
traditionally this is what it says in
the Bible I'm a religious person I
believe in God I live in the Muslim so
you do think that the woman becomes the
men I think she takes his last name I
mean let's watch the clip that you said
about sure so that we can get it in
context
so I think my sister is my her husband's
property yes when a bride is walking
down the aisle to marry the groom the
father walks next to her and gives her
away true or false but I've I've been
married twice as it turns out and on
both occasions I didn't believe that the
woman was being handed to me as chattel
as property it and perhaps the way that
that the reason I'm asked that question
repeatedly and I'm asked in a loaded way
so would you rephrase what you said
there now what that's that's an
interesting point about phrasing the way
I would say things before I was famous I
have to take personal responsibility and
accept right that if I make a video that
500 people see and one percent of them
misunderstand it that's not a problem if
I make a video that 5 million people see
and one percent of hit them under so
specifically on that point I think my
sister is a husband's property she took
his last name she she married him she
wanted to join his family she has seen
it herself right so she she's still a
sovereign individual she's absolutely
property means that the husband owns
your sister listen my friend if you want
to argue about this you need to go back
to the Bible to the Quran you need to
argue with religious no no I'm not
talking about anything in the Bible of
Quran but that's what it says no no I'm
asking you what you think I think that
if a woman marries a man and she decides
to take his last name that they have
different roles and responsibilities
within that marriage and I believe that
that's not the question she's had I
believe
like a politician the father hands her
to the man right but don't be a
politician because I think you're a
straight talker right you keep telling
me you're straight talk I think my
sister is her husband's property do you
regret saying it like that I I
understand that with my newfound Fame
perhaps it could be phrased differently
however I still believe that a woman is
given to the man in marriage that's what
I believe yeah but not as property now
the property is the word that other
people use the question but as a an
equal partner in a loving Union that's
what marriage actually means it doesn't
mean when you get married the woman is
given to you as a bit of Chapel agreed
so why say it uh but that's the way that
people ask me the question people say to
me they asked me you can't blame people
for asking you questions surely if you
want to be accountable for what you've
said you've got to own your responses
don't blame the question I own the
response let me ask you a question now
and you say something and then say well
actually I blame you for us I understand
peers peers I understand I believe the
woman is given to the man I believe
she's given away by the father I believe
she belongs to the man so she belongs to
fundamentally right so fundamentally you
do believe that a woman becomes a man's
property I believe she belongs to the
man in marriage correct right
I see that to me is misogyny and you're
entitled to your opinion right but do
you want do you not understand why
people think it is misogyny I understand
why some people can be very offended by
what I say what they do is they take a
point like that and they ignore all the
other points I make the other way right
that's why that's why I've repeatedly
asked you about that line to see if
you've changed your position but the
reality is you haven't it's not about
changing positions I'm a full-grown
adult and I stick by the things I say
and I'm responsible for them which by
the way is fine absolutely so what you
did say at the start of this little
exchange you said you know I wouldn't
maybe say things the same way now that I
did before I was famous and yet actually
you've doubled done it's an exactly the
same thing on certain points so that is
what you believe that's my point yes I'm
trying to work out look I don't know you
we just met right yeah I'm trying to
work out who Andrew Tate is and what you
actually believe I don't want to twist
anything at all then maybe make it very
very clear to the camera I believe a
woman is given to the man in marriage I
believe that I also believe a man has a
duty to protect and provide for her I
believe a man should lay down his life
if something happens or his wife's life
is threatened I believe that when women
and children first are on the light boat
why
but a man doesn't own a woman it's not
no it's honestly literally buy them as a
slave well obviously we're not talking
about that we're talking about religious
biblical marriage we're talking about
something else yeah but I'm a Christian
I don't believe that I I I own my wife
do you believe your wife was given away
to you when she took her last name I
believe that there is a process where a
father traditionally walks his daughter
down the aisle and hands his daughter to
this man and they stand there and become
a union of two loving people in a
partnership no because there's no
ownership involved I didn't say he's all
selling her the Father of the Bride
isn't selling his daughter no absolutely
means she becomes a member of your
family I think we're arguing over
semantics we're not there because
fundamentally I don't believe a man owns
a woman you do well I don't think a man
owns any sovereign individual I don't
think we live in the world of slavery I
don't own any man or any woman right
nobody owns when you use phrases like
property that's what you imply and so my
point again is you're a smart guy right
there's no denying that you're a smart
you're good good talker I've seen a lot
of the stuff but when you what what I
don't think you quite fully understand
now I understand when young
impressionable people I understand you
are not as smart see things like I think
my sister is a husband's property yes
and you've just reaffirmed that yeah
that belief they think that they have
the right to own women I understand that
very well Pierce which that's why people
think you're a misogynist completely I
understand all of this very well which
is why when you're saying I was
backtracking I'm not I'm generally
regret though over the way you phrase
this stuff well this is the point I was
trying to make
the point I'm trying to make is when I
was not nearly as famous and I was
making long format content I was not
sitting there anticipating I've become
the most Googled man in the planet and
that few seconds could be taken out of
context that was not my anticipation but
it's not what you believed it's what you
believe now so what's the difference
it's not about it's not you're asking me
you're saying that young people who are
impressed you said to me look look peers
honestly I've had time to think about
this and I wish I hadn't said it I don't
believe that that's one thing actually
you've said the opposite you said
actually that's what I think yeah I
think that when uh so it doesn't really
matter whether you recorded it when you
famous or not famous it's what you
actually believe right I believe that a
man has a duty to protect and provide
for a woman I believe that uh a woman's
father gives her away to the man that's
what I believe and that's in in my
marriage that's that's the circumstance
I'm going to live under if people want
to live in a different scenario that's
completely theirs they're prerogative
you went on to say about authority over
women if I have a responsibility of it I
must have a degree of authority yeah for
the same reason if I have responsibility
over and people are going to lose their
mind it's an example an energy
responsibility over a child I have to
have some Authority so you believe as
part of your ownership or your property
of of the woman you have authority over
her no I believe if you ever that's what
you said I believe you've ever
responsibility over something you have
to have a degree of authority you can't
be responsible but Authority means again
that you're the boss the point I'm
making if you'll please let me finish at
this point the point I was trying to
make was talking about the safety of a
woman she was walking alone at night and
I was saying well I wouldn't let my
woman walk alone at night and they said
well you're not in charge of her you
don't get to decide what she does I say
I understand but if I'm responsible for
her safety and I'm the person who's
burdened with making sure she is safe I
have to have the authority to say don't
put yourself in unsafe situations the
two things are linked well you don't
have an authority you have the you can
absolutely have the right to say to the
woman you're with I don't think you
should but ultimately if she decides
that I can't force her right so
Authority implies that you have the
ability to control someone now Authority
believes the authority implies that I
have the moral right to sit and say that
that's an irresponsible thing to do and
I'm responsible that's not what
Authority means well I'm I'm not gonna
if you think I'm gonna lock somebody up
in their room if that's is that what
you're implying no I just think I don't
think you know Authority means I know
what it means I'm saying that this is a
different description of authority if I
have responsibility for her safety then
I have to have the authority to tell not
to do unsafe but Authority means that
you have some form of control over this
woman
I I think you're trying to what you're
trying to I'm only trying to get to what
you think honestly I am I come with No
Agenda here at all I understand and I'm
explaining very very clearly if I have
responsibility of a said subject I have
to have authority of it so let me say
you have children right right you have
responsibility for them I have I have
legal authority over my children that is
very different having legal authority
over my wife or my female partner
completely but the point I'm trying to
make so you accept that I I accept that
you use the analogy of responsibility
for a child my friend these are these
are very these are actually really
important things they're important
things but you introduce you introduce
you interrupt me every five seconds so
it's hard for me to actually explain my
point the point I'm making here is very
simple you have children and you're
responsible for their safety so you're
gonna have authority to say don't go out
at night perhaps because you want them
to be safe you have legal Authority you
have a legal Authority yeah legal
Authority I'm saying that if I had a
woman and the question where you've
raised a sound bite from I was asked
about protecting a woman making sure
she's safe and I would say I wouldn't
want her to go out at night on her own
because I'm responsible for her safety
and someone said well
you don't have authority over it to do
that and I said well no I can't force
her to stay inside but if she were to
ask me how do I protect myself at night
I would say well you should stay inside
that's how you should do that's I don't
have an issue with so we agree no it's
the semantics no it's not it's not
semantics and this is what I don't think
you quite get why there's a fury over
what you say with respect because the
semantics point would be we're saying
the same thing in different ways but
we're not I'm saying to you that when
you say I have to have some authority
over a woman I say to you you have no
right to any authority over a woman you
do over a child if it's your child
because you are the legal appointed
guardian of that child you're not a
legally appointed guardian or authority
over your wife or female legally
appointed absolutely not I agree however
when it comes to things like personal
response or personal safety men largely
by Society are accepted we're the
protectors and providers we can sit here
and pretend that in the world we live in
if me and my wife were walking down the
street and men were to come up and try
and attack us I wouldn't be the one
fighting but we both know in reality I
would right I have a degree I have a
degree of responsibility to protect her
survive a degree of responsibility to
protect her physically then the point
I'm trying to make is I will do my best
to make sure she's never putting herself
you wish you hadn't used the word
Authority The Authority is something
that she would give to me she would come
to me and say how do how can I make sure
but I don't interrupt you I just want to
point out that's not what Authority
means if someone gives you can a person
can get voluntary Authority is not
Authority no but that's the point
Pierce if a woman comes to me and says I
want you to keep me safe she is handing
me Authority for her safety but do you
understand the difference between having
authority over somebody and somebody
giving you permission to have authority
completely I never said what is
consensual and one isn't but why are we
pretending I do unconsensual things
because you literally say I must have a
degree of authority I have to have some
Authority and the point only if I'm
responsible for her safety if I'm not
responsible if your position now is that
with her permission I would like to have
authority when we go out at night to
protect it that's a diff that was always
my position that's not what you said but
that was always my position so again I
simply say to you do you it is what I
said do you wish you'd phrase it a
different way no because we're talking
about long format copy where I'm talking
about a woman who has come to me and
said you're responsible for making sure
I'm safe I said well then I have to make
the decisions but an 18 year old boy
reads I must have some authority over a
woman what do you think he thinks well I
understand that and I said this earlier
when you tried the sales backtracking
which I'm not doing I don't know okay
I'm not trying to gotcha you cool I'm
trying to work out exactly what you I
understand with massive Fame comes
massive responsibility I understand that
a percentage of the population are
always going to take everything that's
said by anybody out of context would you
change the wording of what you said no I
would just encourage people to watch my
long format copy and understand would
you tell an 18 year old boy you don't
have authority over women absolutely you
would say that unless a woman comes to
him and says you're responsible for my
safety please make sure keep me safe
about that Andrew Tate I can sign up to
well then we agree yeah but I don't
agree with what you said before because
you're taking a sound bite from a two
hour but you haven't been taken out of
context because I read you the entire
sentence it's very you've ignored all
the context around the sentence my
friend you can't ignore a sentence that
says I must have a degree of authority
but you can win there's a two-hour
conversation where a woman is telling me
if she makes me responsible for her
safety and me explaining well if I'm
responsible for your safety I have the
authority to make decisions yes you can
order all the contacts do you respect
women absolutely why wouldn't I do you
think the 18 19 year old woman are more
active and 25 year old woman I think
there's Attractive people uh that's
that's a loaded question I don't know
it's not really is it I I can't know why
I'm asking you of course I do but I
can't sit here so the benefit of you is
you don't know why I'm asking you said
this in general this is also one of the
reasons men find youth attractive you
want to blow up the internet or block
the internet right effing now the reason
18 and 19 year olds are more attractive
than 25 year olds is because they've
been through less dick people say oh you
can't say that but yes I can a 19 year
old is more attractive than 26 year old
woman and I'll tell you why because that
26 year old has talked to more guys been
to the club more times being effed and
dumped more times more arguments More
Mess more for me to clean up that is
misogyny why because you are encouraging
a mindset about 25 year old women that
makes them sound out to be
infinitely less desirable than 18 19
year olds and having effectively been
having too much sex to be taken in a
more respectful way that would well
firstly even if that was the case they
wouldn't be misogyny but what did you
mean by what you said that's not
misogyny because it's not anti-women I'm
saying that an 18 or a 19 year old woman
would be more pretty anti-25 year old
woman anti-25 year old women we can
argue but not misogynistic well that's
massage that's no no no it's not being
anti-any woman at all is misogyny not
when I'm not what I'm saying that women
are beautiful and attractive at a
certain age and saying the ages you're
saying 18 19 years are more attractive
than 21 other than ageist perhaps but
misogynistic absolutely but you just
accepted it was misogyny no I didn't you
said it was more Sergeant I'm telling
you no it's not so you don't think if
you're saying slightly hateful things
about it that's not slightly hateful
well it is you think you you say that to
a woman's face if she's 25 it's not
slightly hateful when you would go up to
25 if you're a woman and tell her
exactly what I've just read why would I
walk up to a random 25 because you said
it in public it's on the internet and
it's been listened to and watched by
millions and millions of young
Impressions there was a large panel
there was a conversation whereas hours
Longs of conversation there were
feminists attacking men for toxic
masculinity and attacking me and saying
things and I said things back which
we're going to enter and I think see I'm
I so which you've done yourself a bunch
of times I think a lot of allegations
are toxic masculinity are not toxic
correct I do think that kind of uh
sentence I just read out that paragraph
is actually toxic if you genuinely mean
that and you say you wouldn't say it to
a woman's face but you said it in public
about women of that age I do think
that's misogynist and I think you
probably do too I don't think it's
misogynistic I understand why it can be
insulting you wouldn't say it to a
woman's face well it depends you're
making out like I'm walking around the
street going up to random 25 you're
doing it to tens of millions of people
online there's no difference not at all
we're discussing a topic we're
discussing the the ideal age of a man
should should young boys right in their
teens are you comfortable that they
would have that mindset be honest I
think that young boys in their teens
lack life experience they lack nuance
and they need to be very very careful
what they're digesting online whether
it's my content or anybody else's I
think you know for a fact millions of
them are digesting exactly what you're
saying completely the entire internet to
a degree I think any any subject you can
find there's going to be a whole come
back to the Joe Rogan thing Andrew a lot
of what you say I agree with yeah right
I do genuinely I've read a lot I've
written a lot of stuff you said a lot of
the stuff you talk about I think it's
got a good point right something agree
about a lot of things but when I read
that kind of thing I'm like
I just how much of that is you how much
of that is some ACT do you regret saying
stuff like this I don't actually do you
see it as weakness to admit you
shouldn't have said something like that
no I don't live with regret I think
what's happened is that like I said long
format content arguments with feminists
arguments with the toxic masculine crowd
arguments with the left and they're
going to take a small clip small
sentence from hours and they're going to
try and paint me but I'm not left or
right
I don't know what you are Pierce exactly
that's my point that's my point and I
understand and and you're doing exactly
as I knew would happen on this interview
which is because you're a busy man
you're not gonna watch hours and hours
and hours of video actually I haven't
watched thousand hours of video and I'm
going to come to the stuff where I agree
with you and I'm going to come to the
stuff about your censorship which I have
issues with so this is It's a Long
interview right sure I just thought off
the top you said to me and you were
quite bold about it well go on then
let's go through this and you and you
should keep going I will sit here and
stand by what I said I believe that oh
man on that I just read to you then yeah
do you wish you hadn't said that
I understand how it's been misconstrued
I understand how it's been weaponized
against me do I regret it because it's
been weaponized and used against me well
that's slightly annoying did I that's
not why did I at the time mean what I
said and in the context of the
conversation which obviously you you're
not familiar with and the people at home
are not familiar with no I meant what I
said the 25 year old women have just
talked to more guys been to the club
more times been effed and dumped more
times more arguments More Mess more for
me to clean up well there's a whole much
there's a whole bunch of context and
conversation around that that's been
missed and I don't think I'm missing
much context well I I encourage people
who are interested to go watch it right
but I mean I've just read out three
sentences on the bounce there I don't
think there's any context I'm missing I
mean you you've made it pretty clear
what you think about the difference
between 18 and 90 year old women I
wasn't talking about myself even I was
explaining I was talking with a Muslim
guy who was on the panel and he was
explaining how youth is very valid
valued in most parts of the world and
why Virginia is valued in both parts of
the world and the feminists were arguing
against it and I was sitting there
actually very much like you a mediator
between the two explaining why in most
of the world still today perhaps not in
the Western World virginity is Coveted
youth is Coveted in most of the world
and per and throughout all of human
history and I was sitting there making
the point explaining why in certain
parts of the world they think how they
do well even though it's very different
to the Western World so I was making a
point mediating between two groups very
similar to yourself the conversation has
been misunderstood they've taken this
clip of it and it's been weaponized and
used against me I understand that is
because I'm now the most famous Google
person on the planet it's inconvenient
sure but I'm definitely not a danger to
women in any regard I date women 25 26
27 years old all the time none of them
are offended by the thing I don't think
you're a danger to women I think that I
think the danger if it concerns you the
danger is the influence you have on
young men to have this kind of mindset
about women and that's really what I'm
trying to get to what you really believe
and how much you've just shot off
because you think it's like entertaining
and you haven't really given it much
thought and whether now you're a bit
older and you've had all the Fallout
where the part of you is thinking
actually if I had as Joe Rogan says if
you hadn't said stuff like this you'd
probably still be on these platforms
you'd be massively more popular
massively more famous massively richer
so I'm really just trying to get to on
the blatantly misogynist stuff do you
just wish you hadn't said it with great
power comes great responsibility it was
certainly said before the great power
came it's inconvenient to a degree
however like I said at the time with the
context of the conversation I know that
I'm not saying things which I believe to
be detrimental to the world however
they've been misconstrued and they've
been misunderstooded if a 25 year old
woman was watching this would you say
I'm sorry for saying that oh I wouldn't
want anyone to be offended by anything I
say but I say things when I say things
that offend and this is the thing that's
interesting Pierce please let me finish
are you again maybe like a politician
but hang on you could say I'm
interrupting you do but you're answering
a different question to what I asked you
so as an interviewer okay sure okay sure
okay you accept that that's accept we
both got it on okay so again my point is
simply if a 26 year old woman is
watching this and has heard those
comments would you just say to her look
I'm sorry I shouldn't have said that no
I won't I will say that I am sorry that
that offends you however there's a large
contingent of the world it doesn't mean
you're sorry no I'm not sorry that's the
point I'm making I'm sorry if that
offends you however there's a large
contingent of the world that believed
that and I was mediating for a
conversation parts of the world that
believed that about 26 year old women
are parts of the world where women are
not allowed out on their own that's your
that's a conversation you have to wear
full burkas well that's a conversation
you're not allowed to drive cars that's
nothing to do with it but is that the
kind of world for a woman I was
mediating a conversation I'm asking you
what you think I I don't live in a
country where that happens you're using
that as the excuse for why you're not
sorry for saying it there are parts of
the world but this is fine my question
to you is well do you think it's fine I
don't think it's fine I live in a world
where you don't think it's fine my the
reason this isn't that hard Andrew you
can simply say beers you know what with
the benefit of hindsight I wish I hadn't
said it like that and if a 26 year old
woman's watching I'm sorry I said that
because that actually is blatantly
misogynist and even though that's the
view held by other parts of the world
it's not a view I share now I would
respect you more if you said that yeah
than if you try and say Well it said in
other parts of the world so I'm not
sorry I think that doesn't tell me what
you think then you need to understand
why my content existed in the first
place my content existed because I tried
my very hardest to be an absolute not a
realist especially with uncomfortable
truths I was pointing out that very
uncomfortable is that a truth it's an
uncomfortable truth in many parts of the
world it's not a proof that I'm happy
about it's not true no hang on you're
doing it again
what do you mean that's a truth in other
parts of the world that's what you said
it's not you're not talking about
another part of the world you're talking
about what you believe is the difference
between 18 and 90 year olds and 26 year
olds I was talking about your belief I
was talking about what the people on the
panel believe the difference is
so what do you think the difference is I
think the difference is age what's the
difference though well then 26 year olds
older than the 19 year old and so you
stand by what you said about talking to
the guys been to the club a long time
being left to dump more times why do you
believe that or not no there's plenty of
26 year old women who have been with one
man or a virgin of course so you don't
believe that I don't think that the age
is the only thing that's going to
decipher well how many men and women so
if you don't actually believe what you
said just say sorry it's not about not
believing what I'm saying it's about you
understanding that there's large
conversations going on I'm just reading
back stuff you've said I know I'm asking
you do you believe it I believe that
it's more likely a 26 year olds had more
Partners than a 19 year old right you
don't know that I don't know that you're
right in fact there could be absolutely
no evidence for that whatsoever
completely agree so why say it my
stigmatize all 26 year old women were
it's not about we're repeating ourselves
here but not really I'm just trying to
get to what you actually believe I
believe that men find youth attractive
in general I believe that in the context
of the conversation five-year-old women
aren't old I agree with you they're not
especially they're I'm old you're you
know I'm a lot older than that the point
I was making was part of mediating a
panel a conversation between feminists
and some Muslim guys I get it I get it
because you understand why I said the
sentence but as far as I know you
weren't espousing what a Muslim man
might think you were espousing what you
think I was espousing what the people on
the panel believed but you were saying
what you think
is is I I feel like you're trying to pin
me down if it's not what you believe
just say I don't believe that
what part wouldn't I believe well you
tell me which part you don't believe
there's the sentence which part would
you now say you don't believe
I believe that 25 year old women perhaps
have had because they've been alive
longer maybe have had more Partners but
I don't believe that makes them a bad
person right but you understand that the
way you phrased it makes every 25 year
old I understand a bad person no I don't
think so of course you do not stupid
come on peers Angie you're not stupid
you know what that sounds like to any 25
26 year old woman completely and you're
right so you have maligned every 25 26
year old woman with that statement and
I'm simply asking you to all those who
are not of the type of women that you've
described it are you sorry I don't want
anybody to be offended by anything I say
I want to be a positive force in the
world I don't want anybody to hear what
I say and make them feel bad about
themselves I want all people to live
righteous and good whether they're male
or female and anybody you need a
righteous life I think I do yeah do you
yeah and you boasted openly of adding
six seven Partners at once so is that
righteous there's no moral View From Me
simply asking you what you think
righteous means I think righteous is
living true to your heart and knowing
that you're doing good by people not
snaking anybody not lying to anybody I
know I live a very righteous life
have you ever been in love yeah how many
times uh plenty I believe in love
between men and women I'm a real love
you know yeah I believe how many times
would you say enough I believe men and
women are a beautiful Union I think
we're slightly different but when we
work together with the most powerful
force in the world how many women have
you loved
I don't know pierce my few give me a
Bullpup 5 10 20. let's let's say you
don't forget how many people you've been
in love with let's say 10 I mean I've
been in love and I certainly believe
that men and women when they work
together it's the most beautiful force
on the planet I believe in family I
believe in children I believe in if you
believe in family and children and love
yeah why are you single I'm not single
well you're not married that's what I
mean well if I was married the last
thing I would do is advertise it to the
feral Psychopaths on the internet so a
lot of federal psyched about well like
you call me friend earlier it can be
debated Pierce but the point the point
but the point I'm making as a whole is
that all of these do you want to get
married if I play no but let's let's
please for example let's please for a
second because you've interrupted me so
many times I've failed well actually
I've only interrupted you just be clear
when you've actually answered a
different question cool well then on all
these points and you've admitted that on
all these points you're making on repeat
you're making you're taking these
sentences and on repeat you're using to
what you're weaponizing them against me
I'm not weaponizing anything okay it's
fine no no the more weaponizing the
weaponizing well it doesn't exist no
problem but you said to me come on bring
it on read out all the things that you
think are blatant misogyny all I've done
is literally read out all the things we
identified from all the research that I
thought were blatantly misogynist I'm
giving you the chance to respond and the
only time I've interrupted you is when
you've tried to answer a completely
different question understood peers
the but these things were said in large
context where often I'm talking about
how
for example on the same podcast where
you've read one of them sentences from I
was talking about how it's a man's duty
to die by a woman and the guy asked me
said if 10 men if 10 men with knives
attacked your woman wouldn't you just I
said yeah I'd stand and die I'd never
just run away because I have a duty as a
man I must I must die on the spot to
protect her honor and my honor I'm
talking about a man having
responsibility to his duties I'm talking
about the old traditional ways of
masculinity and what happens is a few
sentences from such a long conversation
is taken and used against it I
understand that so I want you to
understand that I'm talking about
protecting and providing for women I'm
talking about a man if you want to get
married no but this is we have to we
household feed into each other peers I'm
talking about protecting a whole
question no but I'm talking about
protecting and providing for a woman I'm
talking about a man being responsible
for her I understand so of course I
believe in men and women of course I
believe in love of course I believe in
marriage of course I believe in family
the idea that I don't believe in the
idea that I don't believe in these
things if you believed in it I asked you
if you're going to get married one day
absolutely you'd like to if I'm not
married already I would I will be
married one day if I'm not well you
might be secretly married I I could be
married correct why would you not tell
me either way why would I advertise to
the feral Psychopaths of the world who
have tried their very best to destroy me
for an opinion about my private life and
the things that are most sacred to me
why do you think if you said you were
married if one would hate you I don't
like people hate me it's about me
understanding that I'm a hard target but
I am very very protective of the people
I care about right but you believe in
the concept of marriage completely
that's what we were talking about the
whole time what do you think we talked
about a man giving a woman away I
believe in marriage more than anybody I
believe in marriage and no please I
believe in marriage in the traditional
sense I believe a man has a duty to
stand up and be a real man I believe
that the problem with the world today
that we are facing is that not enough
men are sticking to the age-old ways of
masculinity I believe that me standing
up and saying a man must protect a woman
and provide for her so he needs to make
sure that she's safe he needs a degree
of authority I have no problem with no
but no you but people do have a problem
with it and that's not sorry and that's
the world we're in now I'm over here
sure I don't have a problem with what
you just said here's where my problem
comes right there are a lot of clips of
you floating around on the internet as
you know one of them has you saying bang
out the machete boom in her face grip
her by the neck shut up [ __ ] in another
you say slap slap grab choke shut up
[ __ ] sex
when people see those clips and here you
say those things I agree well I don't
think that
it's all hard to misunderstand it it is
you might say that it's consensual other
people would say whether it's consensual
or not that's a very ugly way to talk
about women completely now that's
hitting them with machetes no watch the
whole video it's a girl coming at me
with a machete and me saying here slap
the machete out of her hand she's
attacking me so you don't understand
this is the exact point no people don't
watch them in full and this is actually
what's interesting and please don't
interrupt me on this point social media
has changed in Modern Times YouTube five
years ago was five six seven eight
minute long videos now we have Tick Tock
10 seconds 15 seconds 20 seconds YouTube
shorts Instagram stories now anything
you produce as long form is cut down to
very very short form they're interested
in clicks they're interested in
engagements they find the most they find
the most controversial Clips they can on
purpose you benefited from all that
everybody benefits from social media
views yes do you you're was it the
Hustler what is it I had an online
school called Hustler's University right
and their whole job was to promote your
Clips make you rich and famous so you've
benefited from this system the one you
now profess to hate you benefit I never
said I hate you click they didn't like
the best of them I never said I hated it
I'm saying what happened I don't hate it
I don't hate social media I think it's a
very powerful force I don't hate the
social media I'm saying what is I think
you can talk look you can talk to
girlfriends of yours
um maybe a secret wife I don't know or
two or two maybe you've got ten wise
that's your business I don't care right
my only thing is I don't care what you
do in private if you're consensual
between you and another woman you can do
what you like right it's your life I
believe in freedom and liberty it's when
you said in public it's the influence
that this kind of thing has on young men
I agree right and I speak to someone
with three sons right it's well by the
way they're intrigued by you they're
fascinated right you're you're a big
thing in that world of tick tock and so
on so they all are aware of you and what
you say so they're all looking And when
they see things like the machete thing I
get the context because I'm a 57 year
old guy who's been around the block a
bit and I can get what you said and
you're responding to a particular
scenario which you'd created where a
woman but it can be misunderstood I
understand so my point to you is given
that you know it can be misunderstood do
you regret saying things like this on
camera where it can be disseminated by
less intelligent young males who think
that is actually what they should be
doing to women and finally we get to the
point of the issue which is the point I
tried to make at the very beginning when
I made a video before I was famous they
got 500 abuse me being concerned that
one percent of people will misunderstand
it was not relevant we're not you start
getting five million views of video 50
million views of video one percent of
people misunderstanding doesn't change
no it doesn't but it becomes a much
larger problem and so with great Fame
that's true comes great responsibility
right so I agree would I now I'm famous
do I say things the same way as I did
back before I was famous absolutely not
right as neither would you or nearly any
other famous person on the planet once
you become famous you have to be a lot
more careful with how you say things I
understand so my logical follow-up to
that remains do you regret then saying
it the way you said it I can't live in
regret by saying something before I was
famous on a camera which barely anybody
watched and then I became famous
afterwards that would be a very asinine
way to view the world you can't live in
so you stand by all those I can't live
in regret because I didn't know I was
going to become the most famous man on
the planet that that regret would be the
wrong word is it on is it inconvenient
sure but I can't sit here and say I wish
I knew six years ago I'd be the most
famous man on the planet and monitored
all of my speech forever that's asinine
you see but one of the problems that
people have with you is that
they think you have a malevolent
influence on young people this was the
excuse that was put out by the big Tech
Excuse excuse being the key word well it
may be actually you know I I
intrinsically I have a problem with
censorship I don't think Donald Trump
should be banned from Twitter for
example because the Ayatollah of Iran
remains on Twitter and other social
media platforms and whatever I think of
you you're not the Ayatollah of Iran
right so there's cop there's a to me
there's got to be perspective here and I
don't understand the inconsistency by
what companies like Twitter how they
treat the the leader of Iran and someone
like you seems to me they're much more
Draconian on people like you yeah than
they are with people who perhaps should
not be allowed platforms
um but generally I don't really agree
with no platforming people yeah but I
think what's interesting talking to you
is it seems to me like you have gone on
a bit of a journey of self-awareness
about the impact of some of the stuff
you said in the past and you have said
you wouldn't say it again in the same
way now you may not want to express
regret for that but it shows me that the
very least you have evolved to somebody
who recognizes that these can be quite
damaging in the way that you said them
completely as a professional and as an
adult it would be stupid for me to sit
here and say that now that I'm the most
famous man on the planet my words do not
have more impact than they did before
with impact with power comes
responsibility and things need to be
worded in a very careful way now when I
do a long Format Interview I have to sit
there and consciously understand that
any 10 seconds of that can be cut and
used against me so I can be a lot more
careful with how I say my words and how
I construct my sentences of course we
agree with all of that that's exactly
what's happened to me I agree with all
of that I don't want to be seen as a
negative influence in the world I know
that there's a whole bunch of men I get
thousands of emails a week from men
whose lives I've saved I get thousands
of emails a week from men who were on
the verge of suicide and I've saved
their lives we're talking about and by
the way I don't dispute that at all you
have almost certainly I would think from
everything I've read about you I think
you have certainly been probably able to
be very helpful to young men who have
really struggled for self-confidence and
all that kind of thing right I'm
completely prepared to accept that but
there was also I think quite a
disturbing piece that BuzzFeed did and
he talked about the the negative impact
of young impressionable male Minds when
they've read or seen some of the more
inflammatory things you've said and they
quoted for example Sandy uh 22 from
Washington my father's gone from a man
who minded in women's studies in college
he was kind and in touch with his
emotions treated all people men and
women around him and kindness to a man
who says that whenever he sees an
effeminate male stranger he gets an
overwhelming urge to murder them he
loves podcasts he listens a lot of
podcasts I know he's listened to Andrew
Tate let's stop for a second let's be
professional here appears because you're
a professional azeri firstly she said
did you say that my father when
she said my father has a father that's a
full-grown man firstly so we're talking
about my impact on children you just
talked about full-grown man here
secondly I've never talked about
murdering effeminate men and anything
online ever on in any context ever so I
don't know why they have taken some
random person I've never met in the
world who's full grown an adult and come
to their own conclusion so I've never
met and lumped his name in with mine
that is absolutely unfair on every level
I didn't watch I didn't read this one I
didn't read this BuzzFeed article but
after hearing the first point I know
it's trash that is complete garbage what
is part of the reason this man believes
what he believes I have seen a quote
from you and you can tell me what you
feel here about this sure you talk about
people don't want to see men dressed up
in dressy transgender that's not exactly
what I said what did you say I said the
reason I am so popular and I'm so famous
is that there's a large contingent of
men who don't want to wear makeup who
still want to make money go to the gym
be strong drive a fast car be
traditionally masculine and don't want
to be shamed for that and they don't
want to be called toxic for that that is
the reason I'm so massively famous that
is what do you think of transgender
people that's nothing to do with me I'm
not transgender and I don't understand
the issue like they do they can do
transphobic do you you consider yourself
that transfer well afraid uh would it
kind of yeah I don't live in fear my
friend I I have no problem you have a
dislike of transgender people I don't
know any transgender people you're
dislike of what they stand for what they
are no why would I I don't know that's
not my issue that's not my issue and
that's actually quite interesting
because when I was attacked a lot of
these stupid articles like BuzzFeed
because it's ridiculous that whole that
first point proves anyone with a brain
knows that that's garbage when they
attacked me they lump a whole bunch of
things in together they say misogynistic
racist transphobic they just put them
all together I mixed race by the way I
don't know where they get these they
just get these buzzwords
I completely agree it's crazy and I've
had the same thing done to me okay and
I'm not calling you anything I'm asking
you what you personally believe you are
I it's not an issue I discuss what I do
discuss is that do you support
transgender people Trent I I support
individual liberty I'm a Libertarian so
you support transgender people sure
sure why not exactly yeah so but my
point is as a whole you're saying that
I'm saying I don't want to see men in
dresses I'm saying no I'm just poor gay
people sure yeah I'm saying there's a
large contingent of men in the world who
like the idea of the traditional
masculine view of the world who feel
happy when they watch 80s action heroes
with big muscles and they run around and
there's nothing toxically masculine
about having a fast car and a beautiful
girlfriend and making a bunch of money
nothing at all absolutely and those are
the people who are my fans
but the problem is okay I'm going to
interrupt you just to say this no no
okay but this you're saying that I have
a problem with hit men in dresses I'm
saying no the people who watch my
contact question you've answered yeah
but the people who watch my content
don't want to see men in dresses clearly
I don't wear a dress
well why they're watching your content
no you're not wearing a dress no but
that's the point I'm making that's the
point I was making there's a large
contingent of men who are not interested
in the things that's perhaps the YouTube
algorithms trying to feature I look when
you support masculinity and masculine
traits I'm with you right okay so you
agree a man should protect and provide
for a woman absolutely okay so you agree
if you're walking down the street with a
woman you'd be you'd be responsible with
her safety uh yeah cool absolutely so if
that woman wanted to walk alone I don't
think I have authority over the world as
we do that okay so let me ask you
another question Pierce because we are
professionals let's say your woman
decided she wanted to take a nice little
walk through the south side of Chicago
at 2 A.M and she wanted you to go with
her and you were responsible for
fighting and dying on the spot if she
was attacked don't you think you would
say to her no we're not going out right
now it's not safe yes okay so you'd have
authority to make the decisions no it
wouldn't so I would say I don't think
you should if she decides to it's her
own volition well if she decides you're
not going to stop I have no power to
stop her completely but you think you do
no I don't think I Powers no I think I
have power to make the decision I think
no that's not something if you have the
power to make a decision you have hard
to stop it no because that's where we
differ that's why I think it's
interesting about you I don't think you
really think through what you're saying
I think through what I'm saying because
we're so careful but Andrew you've
literally just said is that you have the
power to stop no I said I don't have the
power to stop her I'm not going to lock
her in the room I'm saying that so she
wants to go on her own then she's going
to go then but it doesn't have authority
to stop okay but as a couple if we're
going to sit there and decide if we're
going to take this would I feel a sense
of responsibility for a safety
absolutely agreed absolutely
power or authority to stop her doing it
no no of course not so let me finish
beers you're not going to stop her
walking out the hotel of course it's her
decision she's a sovereign individual my
point is that usually in a couple people
have you'd sit there as a team and you
discuss and perhaps on certain issues
the woman will know more about X and
she'll decide X and the man might know
more about why and he'll decide why so
I'm saying if we're as a couple and
we're sitting there and deciding as a
couple as a team and she says she wants
to take this late night stroll I'm going
to say you know what I'm going to veto
this one I'm going to call them do you
believe in this dangerous right which
two degree would give me in that
particular scenario I'd agree Authority
if she said I don't want to listen to
you it doesn't give you Authority she
says I don't want to listen to you
Andrew I want to go on that walk then
what can I do say well then I don't have
authority I hope I wish you the best I
love then you don't have authority cool
then it's a semantic argument not really
I think it's the complete opposite of
what you said yeah which was the
authority no problem Pierce no problem
but I think I think we actually about
what do you believe about depression do
you believe depression is a real thing I
believe that feeling depressed is real I
don't believe depression as a clinical
disease is real no really correct you
don't believe people can be clearly
depressed I think PTSD is very real I've
unfortunately I have some friends who
suffer from that and I know that feeling
depressed is real I believe that the
number one power you have against these
things are trying to take control of
your own mind and affecting your own
life I believe that it's not healthy to
hand over all your power and believe
that depression is an outside disease
that you can't affect I know that when
I've had difficult periods in my life
and also many of my friends like I've
said suffer from PTSD and been through
terrible things I've lived a very
difficult life and I know people who
have that the things that made them feel
better is when they woke up and said you
know what I'm not going to allow this to
damage me anymore I'm going to take
responsibility I'm going to get up and
I'm going to fight this as hard as right
and by the way on that I agree so my
favorite speech is the Rocky Balboa okay
so then we agree no we didn't we don't
agree Pierce you don't hang on you've
got to let me sure interject when I
don't agree with you right where I don't
agree with you is that there's no such
thing as clinical depression there
absolutely is well it's a proven
scientific medical reality there's a
different argument about have we gone a
bit too soft right in schools and all
the rest of it absolutely yeah do I
think some people moan and whine too
much about their lot in life definitely
okay are we a victimhood society 100
okay is there such a thing as clinical
depression absolutely so and my argument
is that if you actually bracket
everybody who's not dignity depressed
and doesn't have the genuine medical
condition then actually if millions of
people are deemed to have depression the
ones who really need the help don't get
it well that's my point well that can
that that I would agree with you're
right I think it's certainly overused
terms of things no I don't and that to
me is a damaging view okay well let me
explain why if someone comes to me and
says I'm clinically depressed or I feel
very very sad I would say the first
thing you need to do is stop accepting
the identity of a clinically depressed
person stop accepting you have no
control over this and what you need to
do is stop identifying that way and
let's work together to try and fight
against the reason an eminent doctor in
the world who would tell you there is no
such thing as clinical depression you
would not tell you that I think I think
you're simply Beyond I think Johann Hari
wrote a book saying exactly that my
friend he's not an eminent doctor no but
he is I said depression wasn't real long
ago and was attacked for it then Johann
Hari wrote a book which is because he
wrote a book Proof of me right most
people Johanna Hari is a journalist sure
and and my point is that a lot of people
who are clinically depressed are
suffering with something in their life
and if you fix the problem in their life
perhaps they won't feel depressed
anymore but it's not a disease but
Andrew you're not situational Andrew
You're simply wrong
if that's what you believe Pierce that's
what I believe I don't believe in things
that take power away there is not an
eminent doctor in the world would agree
with this I think you know more than
doctors I can't become clinically
depressed
why do you know because I don't believe
it
I can't be haunted by a ghost if I don't
believe in ghosts well let's say I'm
never going to die because I don't
believe in it it's ridiculous perhaps
but if it allows me to live a life where
I feel happy
again this is that little area where you
lose me no I don't lose you because
somebody with your following so
thousands of people the thousands of
people who have emailed me saying my
doctor told me I was clinically
depressed and it's a disease that I have
got in my brain and I can't be fixed and
I started listening to you and I
realized that that's not the case and I
can fix my own life and you're the only
person who has ever helped me thousands
of people that email me that email if
you think you are single-handedly curing
people of clinical depression you are
living in Cloud curriculum I am reading
the emails of people who I have cured of
clinical depression you're reading
emails from people who have believed you
when you say there isn't such a thing
and they've probably never been
diagnosed clinical depressed they just
want to go along with what Andrew date
says I don't think so and I think your
view of that is that view is dangerous I
I respect that you think my view is
dangerous and I respect you have the
right to view that if you think that I
think that clinical depression I
actually agree with you is massively
over diagnosed I've already said that
PTSD is a very real thing I've already
said I didn't no hang on okay again you
misquited me I I did not say clinical
depression is massively over diagnosed I
said that people who claim to be
depressed but don't have clinical
depression I think that is massively
overblown right in other words there are
a lot of people who just have a bad day
yeah and declare I've got depression
yeah and I I say well have you been to a
doctor have you been clinically
diagnosed if you have and you have
clinical depression that's one thing but
if you haven't we could probably work on
some mental strength and resilience
skills with it but a clinically
depressed person has a an absolutely
proven medical condition that is beyond
their control not according to me and
many others my friend well look what do
you know about it honestly
a psychiatrist you're none of those
things sure you're a guy on the make
he's done very well for himself spouting
stuff off much of which I agree with as
you've seen in the interview uh but some
of which is ludicrous and that's one of
them it's not ludicrous it is it's not
you said to me we're in a victim whose
Society has got to stop I'm with you
okay but the moment you try and deny
clinical depression I believe feeling
depressed is real I do not believe it's
a disease that you catch from the sky
and you cannot affect I believe that no
matter what happens I believe you have
control over your own mind and you can
fight against it I believe if you change
your circumstances in your life you may
feel different I'll give you a quick
example I had a guy who emailed me
saying who's clinically depressed and he
was going to kill himself
I obviously am not a psychiatrist I'm
not a doctor I told him because I
replied to my emails I said have you
been to a psychiatrist he said yes I'm
clinically depressed I've been on these
pills this amount of time I'm on
antidepressants it doesn't work I said I
don't know what to say to besides this
and he said he lost his girlfriend
that's why I became clinically depressed
I said listen go to the gym get a
six-pack first once you've got six-pack
email me again
you still feel like killing yourself I
don't know what else to say to you but
I'd say strong body is a strong mind GO
train
he went he started sending me progress
pictures emailing me him getting a
better better shape and eventually got
six-pack he's not a professional
bodybuilder and he said I can't believe
I was considering that I feel so much
better Etc the doctor was telling him he
was clinically depressed and couldn't
cure it he started taking control of his
own life and now he felt better now I'm
not saying it's the case for everybody
I'm just saying my question have you
seen the guy's medical records of course
not I just told you the student is
taking his word for it oh I am taking
the words of a man who emailed me with a
bunch of medication and specifics you
know it's annoying proven science
because one guy writes to you who you
help and you've not seen any evidence
you ever had clinical depression
diagnosed I'm denying the idea that on
the back of it you go on your your rants
in public to tens of millions of people
denying something because this guy
writes to you and says he had it and you
cured him and I think that's a dangerous
mindset Andrew that's fine that's where
you don't have a responsible view of
your influence disagree it's very
responsible because I'm saving people's
lives I disagree that if you're a diet
if you have if you feel depressed I
disagree that you cannot affect it and
change your life and take control and
fix yourself and feel happier I disagree
with you
I refuse to accept that there are people
out there who cannot become happy
contented individuals I refuse to accept
we live in a world where God has created
people who no matter how hard they work
and how good their life becomes can't be
happy I don't accept that I accept that
the universe is a very giving place and
that God loves all of us and if you try
your best and you work hard you can
become a better person and I also will
argue with you and I'll counter the
point that you sitting here on your
platform telling people they have
clinical depression there's nothing they
can do about it it's far more data okay
well then if they have clinics why do
you misquote no because you're saying
being misquotes no you're saying if
people have clinical depression they
have something to do about it they go to
a doctor and they get diagnosed and they
get help then I would argue the point
that somebody opposite of what you just
said I said I would argue the point that
if somebody has depression of any kind
whether it's clinical whether it exists
or not whether they feel depressed or
not whatever that taking control of
their life taking personal
responsibility and working hard is
always going to be the positive best
thing they can possibly do for their
life going forward
so sitting here saying I don't believe
in clinical depression you don't believe
in depression no I don't I believe that
people can take control and fight
against things right believe in personal
sovereignty right fine good so we agree
that'll be done yes we do no be done
beers are on my side afraid of being
canceled along with me I said to you
from the start that's all I agree with a
lot of what you say completely so I
thought I'm taking you to task over the
stuff I don't agree with you sure and
I'm just not sure you understand why
it's wrong which is in itself quite
revealing let me talk to you about Alex
let me talk about Alex Jones right who I
have a bit of history with each other to
get me deported from the United States
did he yeah what is your view of Alex
Jones I think that Alex Jones is a
sovereign individual who very much like
the Rabid left deserves a chance to
speak on his points of view I think that
the truth on issues is usually somewhere
in the middle between two extremes and I
think you think Sandy Hook was staged I
don't know anything about Sandy Hook
really you know he's just been sued by
the families for millions and millions I
have no idea you don't know anything
about it no so why would you support
someone in public you know nothing about
the most infamous when have I supported
him in public you have supported him in
public I've been on this podcast yeah
but you said nice things about it I say
nice thing things about lots of people
what do you think about exchange I said
nice things about you pierce that's fine
so
to sit and say that I've been on a
podcast and I say nice things about it
you support his right to speak about
things like Sandy Hook I don't know
Sandy Hook I don't know and you know
what it was it was a mass shooting of
school children okay but to sit and and
he's actually no no let's stop for a
second please don't interrupt me
the here's why you're I know why you're
good at your job first you interrupt
people a lot which is good it's a good
skill and then here you go prove me
right but here's the timing is good
here's exactly what I did I only
interrupt people like you when you
either
refused to answer the question or answer
a completely different one sure and I
want to remind you of what the question
was when you misquote me back which
you've done repeatedly through the
interview where you say you see peers
you agree with me and the viewer who's
been watching will go no he didn't cool
no problem the other thing you do is you
try and set these traps like now so
you're saying what's the Trap you think
I'm setting you're saying that I agree
with every single point of view a man
has I literally didn't say that you're
saying well you support Alex Jones why
did you misquote me because you're
saying you support Alex Jones and you
said he you've been on his podcast and
he said this
I don't know what do you think about
exchange I don't know everything he said
what do you think of him I think I think
on his podcast he was cordial I think he
was professional on his podcast I've
also done podcasts with rabid leftists
and and people who openly hate me is it
wrong I do a podcast circuit so and I
don't know everything he's ever said
when somebody like I don't know what so
I don't know what you're trying to get
here because I didn't get a word in
edgewise I'll tell you it's pretty it's
a it's a lame trick if you let me get a
word in I will tell you let's go Alex
Jones said that Sandy Hook didn't happen
it was staged by actors okay this
compounded the appalling grief of the
families of those poor 20 children okay
who were gunned to Pieces by a lunatic
with an AR-15 semi-automatic rifle they
were already Greek strict and beyond
belief and this guy pulled petrol onto
that grief quite deliberately to make a
huge amount of money from his Infowars
fake news [ __ ] and as a result a lot
of the families have now sued him and
they've won and he's gonna have to pay
back tens maybe hundreds of millions of
dollars in damages to these families and
quite right it won't do anything about
the pain he calls them some of them
actually have people turn up outside
their houses with guns because Alex
Jones had told them that these parents
were making it all up they were all
staged actors it was all run by the
government so I simply say to you now
I've told you that what is your view of
Alex Jones
I don't see why any of that has to do
with me I I it's very interesting I've
done the guys podcast I know him well he
was professional and courteous to me
when I meet somebody and they show me
respect I show them back respect that's
what I do as I did with you you respect
him I if somebody shows me respect I
show them respect so I don't know I
don't know if Hitler shows you respect
you'd respect him back
that's a stupid question it's not it's a
logical extension of your argument no if
in 1931 I was walking through Germany
and a man come up to me and said sorry
for bumping into you I'd say sorry no
problem eh I'd show respect that I don't
know what are you trying to say I
sanctioned the Holocaust he literally
just said if somebody respects you you
respect them back I say if somebody
shows me respect I show respect back
that's a good way to go through life
whoever it is if somebody shows me
respect and is courteous to me I'm
courteous fact I didn't respect somebody
who caused such misery and pain I have
no idea the specifics of the thing
you're discussing I don't understand any
of it well I don't know anything about
it when you told me your version of
events when did you go on the podcast I
was on the podcast about four four times
in the last four years I did one really
relatively recently it's a full-time
four times you went on Alex Jones's
podcast correct promoting him helping
him making I think he was promoting and
helping him because well it's his
podcast well yeah but I've been on the
podcast of people who absolutely hate me
I've been on liberal left-wing podcasts
I'm not feminist podcast I know you just
sat here saying I'm I'm I would like you
to agree perhaps we can agree on this
point that I'm not a feminist I go on
feminist podcast I do a podcast circuit
I do not feminist no I don't know what
do you think a feminist is well let's
not change subject here Pierce stay on
the side you mentioned feminism
completely you said you're trying to get
away from the point because what you did
is you're trying to say because I did a
podcast I sanction off this person's
views and I'm saying I do five podcasts
a week I do five podcasts a week and I
don't sanction 100 the views of any
other person on the planet because I'm
an individual and he has an individual
views after you so I don't know why
you're trying to come at me with one of
his views and pretend that's something
it's a pretty big view no but it's it's
a lame trick appears and you're better
than this so let's move on would you
explain
had a podcast would you go on it
sure you would great okay let me know
what you're talking about Vladimir Putin
had a podcast to go on it if Joe Biden
had a podcast I'd go on it if a feminist
has a podcast I'll go on it it appears
Morgan has a podcast I'll go on it if
Alex Jones I mean I don't see the point
you're making there's no point here
you're just you're digging but there's
nothing to find well I'm not I'm taking
your position that if somebody shows you
respect you respect them I think that
I'm saying there are lots of people in
the world I do not respect if Vladimir
Putin showed me in respect I would not
respect him but that's your opinion but
no it's my view okay that's your view
well your still view is you would you're
sitting here peers saying that I'm on
uncensored show and in your intro you
said that it's important that we don't
have Echo Chambers and we have very
correct and that we have varying
opinions right but then you're saying
the people you don't like you wouldn't
go on their podcast no no so you are a
hypocrite no no I will go on anybody's
podcast
I don't think you understand what
censorship means do you like a lot of
words we've had problems with today
you're just saying you what you're doing
censorship means no but the point I'm
trying to make here you know what do you
think censorship means don't hide from
the fact that you're saying you will
only do podcasts with people you like
why do you think that's censorship now
that's your that's your prerogative My
Prerogative is I'll just do with
censorship I'll discuss I'll discuss
opinions with anybody and I've done hard
left-wing why are you not asking me
about the podcast I've done for the
people who are hard liberal by the way I
don't care whether they're left or right
extremists to me uh all nuts right then
we agree yes so perfect good next
subject all right here's my next subject
it's a very serious case here Jesus and
before we move on sorry Pierce but
before we move on I do find it kind of
disingenuous and I know we're on a show
and and I don't have a personal problem
with you but it is kind of disingenuous
to try and sit here and lump me in with
something with some school shooting
that's nothing to do with me I was
that's nothing to do I mean on any level
let me respond any level let me explain
like you've just said you've been on
this podcast four times in four years
since he said the whole thing was staged
I don't know and I simply and I think
the fact that a smart guy like you wants
me to believe you had no idea that Alex
Jones who's been in the news now for the
last two years have been sued by these
families for the most heinous thing
imaginable of pouring petrol onto their
grief by claiming that shooting was
staged the fact that you're pretending
you didn't know about any of that it's
not about pretending you've been on
being on his podcast four times
supporting him and making him money so
damn right I'm going to call you out
when I do a podcast if you think I spend
time analyzing the point of view that
every that of that person and everything
they've ever said for years beforehand
so years it was minutes years and years
you're trying to lump me in and attack
me for a person whose podcast I do
having a view is absolutely childish
because because I've done a bunch of
podcasts I've done a bunch of podcasts
with people who are advocating for
things okay that I do not agree with on
every single level in fact most of my
podcasts are me disagreeing with people
so it's completely crazy that you're
trying to lump me in without it that's
cheap that's cheap you are completely
misconstruing the point of what I'm
saying I think deliberately no no what
you're trying is a cheap trick and I'm
just making it clear I'm just curious
where you're like where your moral line
is it's a cheap trick I disagree with
the points of view with the majority of
the people I do podcast with so it's a
very cheap trick you're trying here so
people invent vile things to make
themselves rich off the back of families
of little kids who've been blown to
pieces with a machine gun
or a semi-automatic version of a machine
gun I think that is actually a line I
would I wouldn't cross I wouldn't be
happy to go on someone's podcast when
they've been responsible for doing that
it's not about political views or
differences of opinion over facts it's
about somebody deliberately inventing a
pack of lies to compound the grief of
families and I just I'm curious you
don't think you have any need to go down
any kind of moral quandary about people
like that before you continue to allow
them to use you for their own promotion
he didn't use me he didn't use me on the
podcast because we disagreed and
discussed points like we're doing with
you right now did you call him out on
that are you using me we didn't discuss
that I'm not using I'm giving you a
platform most people aren't giving you
right now to show the world who you
really are fantastic so neither of us
are using each other I'm here on your
show I'm providing you with content
you're giving me a platform and nobody's
using each other it's mutual we don't
agree on a whole bunch of issues it's
fine and here we are I think we've had a
robust exchange yeah just like I've done
on nearly every other podcast and for if
someone were to come and say say to me
in the future that something heaven
forbid there was a skeleton in your
closet and some were to come to me and
say you were on Piers Morgan's show did
you know he's ex or he's done X I would
say that's absolutely nothing to do with
right but I make the same point
protecting you I don't I don't know what
you do I don't know your personal
guarantee I can guarantee one thing I
will not be inventing stories I have
families I hope you I hope I hope not I
hope you're a righteous person but I
don't claiming to be a righteous person
I don't know I'm just saying that I just
think it's interesting that you have no
moral compulsion about going on people
how about moral compulsions it's about I
don't know what you do Pierce you could
have a bunch of skeletons in your closet
my friend I don't have a clue I'm here
on your TV show I'm sure we all have
lots of skeletons let me know let me ask
let me ask you this interesting about
the feminism thing sure do you identify
as a feminist I think that women and men
are fantastic both of us are fantastic I
think women reproduce I think women need
to be respected protected provided for I
think that modern feminism is kind of
hard for me to even truly what do you
think it means what is feminism I think
that the idea of feminism is that men
and women are equal under the law and do
you believe that completely we should be
treated completely yeah but we are equal
under the law wouldn't you agree uh not
really I think there are still some
issues in the world where I mean
certainly in workplace the gender pay
Gap remains uh they're not treated
equally in most cases women well that
can be discussed the gender pay Gap I
think that's already been discussed at
length I think that there's actually I
think women should go to work I think
women should work completely you do why
wouldn't they because in the parts of
the country of the world you were
mentioning earlier that have different
views of women they don't go to work in
the parts of the world that person from
the podcast was from for the point I
made yeah they didn't but I don't live
in those parts of the world I think
women should be free to work if they
choose I think it's very important that
uh the family unit remains I do believe
that the most in my personal view the
most important and respectful thing a
woman can do is become a mother I think
that having children is a beautiful
thing uh but obviously if women wants to
work and wants to have a career
especially now with paternity leave a
maternity leave and she can manage to do
both why wouldn't I want women to work I
don't know why anyone would ever assume
I don't want women to work or think
women can't work because I said that I
should keep them safe sometimes good no
but it's interesting because you have to
look at this Pierce it's interesting how
people extrapolate Andrew said that
women that he's responsible for a
woman's safety and he said that that
gives him authority to make decisions
for her safety and that's been
misconstrued and he's a bad person he
believes that women are property so but
now we believe that Andrew doesn't
believe in love Andrew doesn't believe
women should work and I don't know where
all of that comes from well that's why
I'm glad we've had a chance to discuss
completely I believe women are sovereign
individuals and they can make any choice
they so desire I think that it's
important that we remember that a man
has a duty I think I certainly in my
relationship have a financial
responsibility to provide for my woman
my woman would never have to work unless
she wanted to because I'm the kind of
person who works hard enough should my
young men though all aspire to be like
you should young men aspire to work very
hard have no criminal record become
multi-millionaires protect and provide
for the women close to them uh be
Sovereign so they can stand up and have
their own points of view in face of
cancellation be able to not be mentally
intimidated when they go on national TV
and there's traps set up for them yeah I
believe that confident strong men who
who stand up and protect and provide for
women are a good thing for the world and
a good Force for the world and I don't
think that I put a magic spell on
anybody I think there's a whole bunch of
men in the world who understands my
value and if if men grow up to be like
me you're gonna have a whole bunch of
people with no criminal record dedicated
athletes who protect and provide for the
people close to them are fantastic for
the economy and we're and I'm not I'm
certainly not the worst influence out
here peers you have little Nas twerking
on the devil on music videos which our
children are digesting you have uh
drillar is singing about stabbing people
to death in the middle of a knife crime
epidemic you have rabid uh Psychopaths
on whether the right or the left
announcing violence on the other side
you have all these insanities in the
world and because I sit here and say I
yeah perhaps now you've laid out and it
offended you I understand
okay cool I just read you the things you
read things that you said it could be
offensive and some people are offended
well some people definitely were
offended absolutely that's fine and
honestly I think some of the things you
said were genuinely offensive and
misogynist okay so they offended you so
like I said earlier so they offended you
which is fine I said they offended you
you interrupted me and now you're saying
they offended you which is fine and the
but the point I'm trying to make is this
I'm not the devil there's certainly
worse people than me
and I'm saying that my core tenants that
the people who don't understand me are
self-accountability so I'm accountable
for everything I've ever said my core
tenants are responsibility so I'm
responsible for everything I've said my
court tenants are traditional
masculinity to a degree which involves
protecting and providing for women and
I'll make another Point another Point
here that's very very that's very that
needs to be said
the number of women who have stood up
and stuck up for me is ignored thousands
of women are making videos saying I've
met entertain such a nice guy I wish I
had a man like Andrew Tate who felt
responsible to protect and provide for
me you know what I I do belong to my
husband that's why I married him and I
love him we ignore the thousands of
women who stood up and prepared and and
stood by me and said everything I said
is true and we're taking a very vocal
minority who have taken things I've said
and are pretending to be absolutely
Nutley devastated by them for some
reason time out sure you've had a good a
good run there sure an inquest this week
found that a 14 year old girl Molly
Russell died from an active self-harm
while suffering from depression and the
negative effects of online content the
coroner said she was exposed to material
that may have influenced her in a
negative way and in addition well
started this depression and become a
much more serious depressive illness and
she's very sadly took her life that's
that's absolutely disgusting right her
father terrible her father's campaign
for better protections against
potentially dangerous social media
algorithms right it says that the
particularly graphic content she or
romanticized acts of self-harm
normalized her condition and focused on
a limited and irrational view without
any counterbalance of normality
first of all what is your response to
that nothing to do with you yes that's
the first thing yeah it is nothing to do
with me the fact that a 14 year old girl
took her life is truly sad the world we
live in today is
the rule we live in the fact that
something like that happened is almost
mind-blowing to me that's truly that's
truly sad I actually feel sad inside to
see something like that the fact that
they just said this romanticizing the
Gory element I don't know what she was
watching some kind of suicide videos
today I don't know where these things
you think the tech companies should be
much tougher about stuff others
I don't know what kind of things she
watched obviously I have to be a
professional here I think that the tech
companies need to do their best to
protect people I guess to a degree but
it's a slippery slope isn't it and then
they use this slippery slope to to
silence some people and to do right and
I think that's a I think it's a really
fine line and it's a complicated line it
is very I was interested when you did an
interview with the times Hugo Rifkin
he's a very good journalist he did a big
interview with him and it was
interesting to me his conclusion because
he kind of concluded that although he
found a lot of the things you said
awful and offensive and he didn't like
them and he didn't want to be that kind
of person that would say those kind of
things nor could he actually work out
exactly what you've done which deserves
Mass wipeout by all the tech firms I
thought it was an instant conclusion I
don't you know I don't know the answer
to that other than the reason I
mentioned the Molly Russell case not
because that has anything to do with you
at all and I reiterate that thank you so
I simply ask you this what has come
clear to me in the interview is that a
lot of things you say you wouldn't say
now that you've said before I thought
I'd say it differently yeah right so to
me that's an acceptance
not just that you want to get back on
platforms because maybe that was one of
the reasons you you were no platform but
that you've recognized and understood
the potential harm to the wrong kind of
impressionable mind
by some of the things you've said would
that be fair I think that's 80 fair I
recognize and understand that with
massive Fame
you have to be more careful about being
misconstrued like I said earlier one
percent of people misunderstanding you
doesn't matter with a small audience it
matters with a very large audience with
power comes responsibility I still
believe the things I say I do not want
to be a negative Force for the world I
also understand that I am a man who's
lived a very difficult nuanced life and
I am capable of making nuanced points
that may be misunderstood by teenagers
however that can be said about anybody
and everything every opinion online can
be misunderstood by children trying to
protect children from the Internet is a
very interesting subject in and of
itself because I would argue that 80 of
the content on the Internet is can be
negative or detrimental to a young mind
that doesn't understand the world yeah
I'd argue that all of it we just talked
about music videos and dancing on the
devil and all this stuff all this stuff
is dangerous by the way I think you make
a very good point on that so a lot of
these rap stars the lyrics the videos I
think far exceed anything that you've
been accused of doing completely because
in a lot of cases some of them promote
non-consensual activity with people
right and I just think that crosses the
line you have as far as I've seen you
haven't crossed that line no I haven't
and I and this is the thing and I've
been vilified not because of the things
I say because much more extremist
content already exists on the internet I
think the reason I've been attacked and
vilified is because of the popularity
because I became so massively famous not
because of what I was actually saying so
as a professional I analyze that and I
understand okay I'm massively famous now
and certain things have been taken out
of context however I still do believe
I'm a Force for good in the world and
I'm not going to sit here have you
changed though I don't it's not about
changing what are these we're all
involved in Evolution how old do you
know I'm 36 36 right I bet you're a
different person to what you were when
you were 26. oh that's fine that's
absolutely so we all change and Mike you
keep talking about being a good person
yeah I think if you're honest with
yourself yeah that you can see why
people found a lot of the stuff you've
said
problematic and misogynist and I think
you recognized you wouldn't express
yourself in that way again because
you've understood that it's caused a lot
of harm and that's really really what I
wanted to get to today was an
acknowledgment by you that these things
clearly were said in the wrong way
created the wrong impression if you
didn't mean them the way you intended
them and can therefore have a malevolent
influence when you have a huge following
yeah when you have a huge following you
certainly have to be a lot more careful
about how you get certain points across
that's absolutely a fact Andrew I
appreciate you coming all the way from
Romania thank you it's been an
interesting conversation and I thank you
for having it cheers man well that's it
for me whatever you're up to Keep It
Uncensored good night